sport le Paris Saint-Germain deuxième de
la Ligue 1 si si en partant du bas son
deuxième
[Applaudissements]
maintenant la revue de presse de
Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
salon de l'agriculture Nicolas Sarkozy
c'est amour haché d'un animal à corne si
Cécilia repart il sera moins seul
une curiosité cette année un port coiffé
d'un chapeau de vache
voilà
et les crânes rasés autour sont en pot
de fesse
à force de penser comme des culs
Le Pen déguisé en cowboy titre La Presse
Jean-Marie aurait été chamboulé par le
film brokebeck Mountain autant vous dire
que dans sa commune à montre-tout c'est
les mois
Simone Veil récompensé pour son
ralliement à Sarkozy un dînait tendre
avec 12 Blazy qui est médecin
rappelons-le les vieilles adorent sortir
avec un toubib ça les rassure
Sarkozy est vraiment trop petit regardez
cette photo mardi à Vesoul il n'a pas pu
serrer la main de ces deux habitants qui
habitent pourtant un rez-de-chaussée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Bretagne protestation d'un village leur
malien ont été expulsés bah ce sont les
nouvelles directives du ministère de
l'Immigration et de l'Identité nationale
allez Malia avait tout son boulot breton
de puissance mais ils étaient incapables
de faire des crêpes il y a eu des
tentatives de crêpes maliennes mais
c'est pas ça ils mettent de l'ananas du
piment Sarkozy il a dit stop à l'école
Gilles de Robien veut réapprendre le
vocabulaire 5 mots nouveaux par semaine
or on commence dès maintenant le son
numéro 1 Nick
ta mère
pour avoir été mise sur écoute par
Mitterrand Carole Bouquet obtient
réparation un euro symbolique c'est pas
cher quand on pense à toutes les
douceurs que c'est fait ton temps en
écoutant les cassettes
international pékin veut réduire le
nombre des exécutions ah attention les
Chinois vont bientôt accueillir les JO
en tir ils sont très bons c'est
peut-être pas le moment d'arrêter
l'entraînement
dans VSD Samuel Le Bihan au Darfour face
à l'horreur sobriété de l'acteur qui
porte un t-shirt siglé action contre la
fin toujours au Darfour Bernard-Henri
Lévy a préféré une veste Dior Polo Ralph
Lauren barbe de trois jours cheveux au
vent un balayage réalisé par Franck
Provost le coiffeur des stars
société vraie ou faux depuis le 1er
février 2007 de plus en plus de femmes
font le trottoir
faux ce sont juste des employés qui
descendent fumer une clope
[Applaudissements]
la société Kärcher en a marre qu'on
ridiculise son nom c'est vrai avec un
karcher on peut nettoyer une voiture des
poubelles et pendant la canicule on peut
hydrater mamie
si c'est moins cher qu'une thalasso
médecine une info libération d'une
région à l'autre les cancers sont plus
ou moins présents alors beaucoup de
cancers du sein en Haute-Normandie en
Basse-Normandie ce sont les cancers du
sein qui tombe et le Bas-Rhin c'est tout
ce qui est cancer du rectum et de la
prostate
sport le Paris Saint-Germain deuxième de
la Ligue 1 si si en partant du bas son
deuxième
chemise Paris Match a retrouvé les deux
derniers poilus il y a également Demis
Roussos qui n'a pas voulu poser le
fameux le Conseil d'Emmanuel Seigner il
n'y a pas que le cinéma dans ma vie je
peux rester trois ans sans bosser ça ne
me pose aucun problème c'est vrai on y
pense pas les caissières de supermarché
par exemple arrêtez-vous trois en
profiter
un scoop it antisémite pardon cérémonies
et on termine en images j'ai madame
guicarlier est enceinte première
échographie en 3D on voit déjà la trompe
et les deux grandes oreilles à la
semaine prochaine merci beaucoup merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu